Ora che abbiamo esaminato tutti gli elementi del VQE,
facciamo un riepilogo di ciò che abbiamo imparato e vediamo come un computer quantistico lo esegue.
Partiamo dal nostro stato di riferimento scelto con cura, dal circuit parametrizzato,
dalla scelta iniziale dei parametri e da un Hamiltoniano.
Passiamo questi elementi al nostro computer quantistico.
Prima che l'Hamiltoniano possa essere eseguito sullo stato ansatz,
dobbiamo eseguire una pre-elaborazione classica del circuit
per renderlo leggibile dall'hardware quantistico, in un processo chiamato transpilation.
È anche importante sfruttare al massimo
l'architettura dei qubit nell'hardware reale per ottenere i migliori risultati.
Questi processi vengono spesso gestiti automaticamente, così non dobbiamo
conoscere esplicitamente la connettività dei qubit,
le fedeltà dei gate e così via.
Ora il compito è misurare lo stato risultante
e stimare il valore di aspettazione, che verrà ulteriormente
ottimizzato da un ottimizzatore classico.
Questa misurazione viene eseguita ruotando la base di misurazione
e poi combinando i risultati delle misurazioni per ottenere il valore di aspettazione.
Questo risultato parametrizzato viene quindi fornito
all'ottimizzatore classico, che trova nuovi parametri per lo stato.
Poi il processo si ripete.
Una pre-elaborazione classica crea un nuovo circuit parametrizzato
e applichiamo lo stesso Hamiltoniano di prima.
Nota che nell'intero processo VQE cambiamo solo gli stati
attraverso i parametri, che si avvicinano sempre di più allo stato fondamentale.
Ripetiamo questo fino a quando non siamo soddisfatti del risultato.
E questo è tutto.
Mi chiamo Victoria Lipinska e questo era un corso sul variational quantum eigensolver.